Let's look at how address translations work.
An, an architecture that supports address space
tags in the TLB. Recall that the
virtual addresses are being generated on behalf of
a particular process, and the process has a process ID that is uniquely assigned
by the operating system for that process. So when we make an entry into the TLB,
what we are storing in the TLB is not only the tag that is associated with a
particular virtual address, but also the PID of
the process for which we are creating this entry
in the TLB. So in other words, every
entry in the TLB is flagged with the process
ID that, that particular entry corresponds to. So
how does address translation work in this address space
tagged TLB? Well, similar to a normal TLB, we're going to take this virtual
address and split it in two parts, the index part and the tag part. The index
part is what let's us look up a particular entry in the TLB. And
from the TLB we get two tags. One tag is the address space
tag. This is signifying which process created
this particluar entry. So what we want to do is,
we want to compare the PID of the process that is
currently generating this virtual address against the tag that is
contained at that entry. And this matching hardware, is going to
say yes or no, if it says no then we
are done, then this entry does not correspond to the virtual
address that we're trying to translate here. On the other
hand, if it does match, this entry does correspond to this
process, then we want to ask the question,
whether the tag that is associated with this
entry, is the same as the tag that
is contained in the virtual address. So that's
a second level of matching that goes on. And only if both the process ID matches
and the tag matches do we have a hit in the TLB. So in other words,
there is two level of matching going on.
And therefore, when we do a context switch from
one process to another process, there is no need
to flush the TLB on the context switch, because
the TLB may contain some translations on behalf
of the previously executing process. And it may contain
some translations that correspond to the new process that
has been scheduled on it. And the hardware disambiguates
these entries by doing this second level
of matching of process ID against the address
space stack that is contained in the
TLB. But, if the memory management hardware does
not support address space tag, then what do we do? And this is a case
for instance, in the Intel architecture, that
the TLB does not have address space tags.